I just wanna cut the sleeves off dude
look very white very widest you only get
that REI climbing very what really oh
there's a lot of black rock climbers are
no there's not
how do you know Brendan oh really yeah
don't go into REI you look a blonde are
you a [ __ ] little Wayne let me how it
goes for now they're climbing a journey
and Boston can you look up black um can
we look alright sorry can we look up you
look at black rock climbers I hope so
I've seen seen solo the best rock
climber of all time did you did it
without a rope oh here we go right here
whoa okay well if you go home black rock
climbers really get it black or how
close man
oh there's a guy right there this guy
something is running from white people
Oh brothers are climbing there
representing reaches in the Arctic it's
a new Jordan Peele movie you can tell it
I saw that coming Brandon put it in the
in the chamber straighten his back a
little yeah let's click on some of these
pictures though there's one with the arm
there yeah that guy oh there we go
that's a white guy rock climbing yeah
black rock climbing or black ah your ass
to be a problem for that rock climbing
dude it's yet it I'm back heavy hmm I'm
built like a book in
[ __ ] someone can that caboose up the
mountain dude look at this guy right
there
Mack City dude Jerome Horton is a good
rock line Richard Lawson he does it too
I'm gonna start doing so I have a
culture it's random you would be you're
pretty you're heavy to feel like you
could bat flip back flip up the goddamn
mountain yeah but I feel like a is there
a lot of Asian rock common there
probably is I could see that being an
American Ninja Warrior they have that
show yeah absolutely the Apple Store
sometimes you gotta climb a mountain to
get to school in China damn that's true
whoa Oh what is this it's dry for next
weekend for some rock climbing who's
this Geron Horton he's a comedian oh
there he is rock climbing go down on the
one more - a little more a little more
right there on the right yeah there he
is
well that's indoor though that's that
are yeah but I went with him but still I
think he could probably do it outdoors
too if he was outdoors you never know to
get out there and try it you know that's
true it's like practice watching about
practice practice practice
you know it does look fun he's tall long
long and like you though if you can
something like it's nothing
yeah he'll go up there and do not he'll
go up there and have a lemonade or
something go up there make lemonade yeah
Nate Stanley get two freakin customers
he'll be a climber up there yeah
Newton he got a strong mouth to us on
one point you just the wall of death and
then move the rock where the Suckerfish
you had a tank is unbelievable moves
coming out of you're on Horton right
there the sucker fish the real MVP when
you think about two of them they clean
the tank for you you don't need the
filter Sudan imagine you're a couple
fish you're at a bar hanging out dude
your wife's out of town right into these
bad [ __ ] roll up these suck do you
know you one of your boys is gonna
you're one your boys gonna feel about
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]